I said what do you got all right this is
some hard-hitting news you guys you like
that too here we go this is CBS this
morning scientists may have found a way
to prevent seagulls from stealing your
food scare them down a study by British
researchers tested dozens of gulls in
southwestern England yes this is real
the birds took more time to steal a
potato chip if the person was facing
them researchers also suggests moving
away or waving your arms over your head
to scare with like so I think they said
put it above your head or act like a
bird this is this is a really good data
point that I really like the researchers
tried to test 74 Birds by placing potato
chips in front of an experimenter and
just 27 of the gulls bit the bait I feel
really bad for the person I'm just
assuming they had one dude just testing
in just 24 times or 27 times he's got
this study actually guys ever been
attacked by any birds here in New York
City I swear these pigeons are after me
they get so close yeah they're not
scared that's for certain now ready to
go with you yeah it's good luck if they
leave an offering on your sure
[Laughter]